- Wow. You are looking
zazzy as hell today.
(swing music)
A blat is a coffee
stain on your brand new,
double-breasted three piece suit.
(buzzer)
My first job, delivering blats.
Throwing blats on people's doorsteps.
Blat.
Off the cob.
When you're living off the cob,
I think you're living high on the hog,
you're living good.
(buzzer)
I really wanted to like her in the meeting
but her fashion was just off the cob.
We can't have that
representing our company.
So I know this is a trick question,
cause you want me to fall
into the trap of hot potato,
but as you and I both
know, you say po-tay-to,
I say po-tah-to,
but we're talking about tomatoes.
That man is well-read, he is a hot tomato.
(ding)
I'm one for three, somebody
call the blat, write it up.
Chaff's the nonsense, that's
the stuff you don't want.
That's the dregs.
(buzzer)
See, you're trying to
play with me in this quiz.
Maybe it's a derivative of pizzazz,
all my instincts have been wrong.
I don't know, like saying
that a girl is fine?
(ding)
(breath whooses)
Gobble pipe.
Meant your throat.
(buzzer)
I knew Bill Clinton was a clinch
for the President when I saw him playing
the gobble pipe on David Letterman.
Nook.
It's a pickpocket.
(buzzer)
A bobby-dangler.
That's somebody's bits and pieces
they talkin' 'bout up in there.
(ding)
A bobby-dangler is
definitely a man's genitalia.
Ninnified.
Is that like someone
who's not very courageous?
(buzzer)
That girl's got some jelly ass.
Was that like, bootylicious
before Beyonce coined it?
(buzzer)
I didn't know it was
gonna be that kinda party,
I thought it was just gonna
be like some hors d'ouevres,
and nobody here was gonna be
jelly assin' on the dance floor.
(laughs)
I think, in the grand scheme of things,
I ultimately operated at about 50%,
which I'm not proud of.
In fairness, it was not
multiple choice for me,
I had to just roll with it.
But now I'm gonna get my
bobbly-dangler out of here,
and I'm gonna go jelly
ass on the dance floor.
Peace.
(jazz music)
(logo whooshes)
(hinge creaks)